Ladies and gentlemen, this is an update to the Whitehead Jr. Story.
If you haven't seen it already, you can go watch it here. Uh,
basically to summarize an ed tech camp is using thuggish tactics to take down
any criticism they deem in any way, negative of them. At the same time,
they try to pretend that they're very accepting of criticism.
I showed you guys that in the last video, of course, it's colloquially known.
Even I was getting comments that they take down stuff. They love to do it.
But what isn't known is exactly how extensive this is, right?
So I'm here to tell you today,
you remember those Slack conversations from last time that were leaked. Well,
someone went through them and catalog all the links.
They were following reporting, monitoring,
trying to get taken down and they actually categorized it in a gigantic
spreadsheet. Okay.
I'm not going to be sharing it on screen because it contains private
information.
And I don't want to give them any false reason to take down this video.
So I'm not going to be sharing that, but if you want to find it online,
you can pretty easily find it.
But the point is I went and I chased down all these links and I checked,
how many of them did they successfully delete their whole case?
Remember is that they're only suing two of their critics for millions of dollars
because they lied. They don't,
they don't mind real criticism from real customers. That's what they say, right?
Here's what we find in actuality, just in the month of October,
I made it October. So it's easy to project out for the year.
They removed 109 posts.
They removed 51 YouTube videos,
51 they're moved 27, Twitter posts, 11 Facebook posts,
15 LinkedIn posts,
three Instagram posts and two posts from the most unlikely source of all
nine gag. Yes, that's right.
Whitehead junior is even monitoring nine gagged for offensive comments.
And they go ahead and get those removed here.
Here are the comments and question. Someone was making fun of one of their, uh,
you know, success stories. That was a big joke. Yeah.
They don't take too kindly to that. They get that stuff removed. And look,
you might be asking yourself, well, Stephen, how do you know that this is,
this is a realist. How do you know that they really are taking them down? Well,
the reason we know these are real is that a lot of them are,
especially the YouTube videos in particular are being manually taken down with
copyright strikes, right?
Even when they don't have reasons to take down content,
they'll take it down anyways. See,
this is one of the comments for one of these YouTubers where they say user has
nowhere use the white hat, junior logo or any copyrighted content in the video.
So you can't copyright strike it because that's how they're getting all these
videos done.
There's no legal point with us to dispute with YouTube on this video.
Trademark certificate might help us to take it down.
But when you go to the video, do you see taken down by a trademark? No.
We see it's taken down by a copyright claim from the same company that's taking
all of these white hat, junior things down. It's one of their, uh, corporations,
I guess they've even gone so far as to get some YouTube accounts banned the
account that posted it all of a sudden gone. Isn't that a coincidence? I mean,
and can we address the nine cat thing, guys? Let me say, look,
there are a few points in life where you got to stop yourself. Right?
We talked about this.
When the guy tried to escape from the FBI with a C scooter, I told you guys,
if you ever find yourself on a C scooter, you know,
you've made a series of poor life decisions. You don't just end up on a C skirt.
The same is true here.
If you find yourself monitoring and censoring posts on nine gag,
which is the platform people go to when they haven't heard of Reddit yet,
and they're stuck in 2009, when you find yourself doing that,
you've taken some wrong turns.
And what I want to say to the leadership of white hat junior,
if I could speak to them for a second,
you guys are playing the victim and it's not working. It's clearly not working.
These lawsuits have hugely backfired on you.
People are now paying even more attention to the topic than they were before.
And you're embarrassing yourselves because look at this, look at this.
This is from the same post from the CEO where he tries to play.
The victim news cycles turned against us because negative stories are far more
sensational than the truth. No, dude, the truth is, look,
I didn't have to sensationalize this. You sensationalized it.
The fact that 109 critical posts were removed in October.
That's already a sensational fact and you created the negativity for yourself.
Instead. You're trying to pretend like, Oh, we didn't want to go to court,
but you sued. Oh, false unethical attacks. What's false.
One of the main criticism that Wolf goop to is a false imaginary character.
You in your lawsuit admitted is true. So you're suing them,
but they're right about their main critical points. So look again,
speaking to the leadership of white hat junior,
you guys have to take a different path. This isn't going to work for you,
this constant censorship. Instead he got to drop the lawsuit,
stop the censorship, admit to messing up and call it a day.
But this isn't going to work. What I'm seeing right here,
taking down a hundred posts a month.
How long do you think you can keep doing that until there's a thousand negative
posts a month? I mean, if there's one thing the internet hates,
it's somebody trying to shut down the internet and that's exactly what you guys
are doing here. No, one's gonna stand for it. And um, yeah,
I just wanted to Chronicle this. Uh,
I've got to just stop this video before it gets too out of hand.
I made my point. So I don't know how long this video is going to be up.
So if you see it, share it, uh, thanks for watching and I'll see you next time.
And don't forget to smash light and subscribe. Thank you.